welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire i've
been sitting in for david pakman today
and hey folks
you know what we really dislike
we dislike socialists here in the united
states
or at least the republicans do right
everybody that is their opponent gets
smeared as a socialist it's socialism
even though most of them couldn't even
tell you what the word means everything
they hate
is a socialist or communist or fascist
even though again they just use those
words interchangeably
because they think that they all mean
the same thing
well now
republican senator marco rubio who is up
for re-election this year his primaries
actually today and he's going to win
because he's the only one
he is being smeared by one of his
libertarian opponents
as a socialist
and maybe smear is not the right word
he's being attacked by his libertarian
opponent
as a socialist libertarian opponent by
the name of uh demis uh dennis excuse me
uh masigoy misagoy
my apologies if i've mispronounced that
but either way mr misagoy
said in a recent interview
that marco rubio
was a socialist
now
marco rubio is many things
but a socialist i i never thought i
would see the day
where somebody would accuse him of being
a socialist but then i read
this article
that was you know an interview with mr
misagoy
he actually makes a good case
and i typically don't say that about
anything that libertarians have to say
but he makes a dang good point
let me read this
rubio is pretty uniquely bad
no argument from me there right off the
bat you got my attention
not just in the sense of being unpopular
and easy to dislike but policy wise this
is a guy who got elected as part of the
tea party wave back in 2010 and when you
listen to him talk about dealing with
issues of economic policy it's all
central economic planning it's not free
markets
i would characterize him by the
republican standards as a socialist is
he a socialist by the means of seize the
means of production to nationalize
everything socialist no
but he's a socialist a socialist by the
obamacare socialist standard i'd say
yeah
okay um
you're losing me a bit there because
obamacare is
in fact not
socialist so gonna have to dang you on
that one mr mizigoy
he continues though
republicans have long presented
themselves as the champions of fiscal
responsibility smaller government and
whatnot i really got turned off to them
in the first part of the 2000s george w
bush was president for eight years for
six of those eight years you had
republican majorities in congress and
what'd they do with the spending and the
growth of government
well
we all know right government grew
spending grew deficits grew all of that
because republicans
are a bunch of
socialists
now i think what mr mitagoy was trying
to get at
is that republicans believe in corporate
socialism right
that's what you want
because republicans love to spend money
they love to give money to corporations
we love to prop them up we love to bail
them out we love to give them subsidies
and tax cuts just for the heck of it
so in that regard yes there's lots of
socialism here in the united states most
of it at the hands of the republicans
going directly into the pockets of the
big corporations
so in that regard if of course that's
the point he's trying to make here
if that's what he's calling socialism
on the behalf of marco rubio i agree
with you 100 percent
now there there does come a point
where i disagree with him
not about marco rubio
but
about something else he said in this
energy
because then he gets back you know to
his libertarian leanings he makes a
couple good points he makes a couple
confusing points that make no sense as i
said with the obamacare thing but then
he goes back to his libertarian ways
which
never make any sense here's what he said
we want the market to be as efficient as
it can be because an efficient market
delivers goods and services to people at
the lowest cost possible lowers the cost
of living overall that makes it easier
for people to live and it leaves more
capital left over for people to create
new things that improve people's lives
further
boy i wish i lived in the fantasy world
that you live in mr misagoy because
literally none of that ever happens ever
and that of course is my big problem
with these libertarians they're living
in a fantasy land
well if we just let corporations do
whatever of course they're going to take
care of people of course they're gonna
lower prices hello
what what on earth like what drugs do
you have to be on
to make you have visions of this world
where corporations inherently do the
right thing
they don't
even with government agencies that are
supposed to force them to do the right
thing they still don't do the right
thing
what i would encourage all of these
libertarians in the united states to do
is go get a job at a plaintiff's law
firm and work there for at least a year
see i've worked with a plaintiff's law
firm including actually other law firms
all throughout the country as well
for almost two straight decades
i have seen some of the worst documents
imaginable
from every industry imaginable
whether it's the tobacco industry the
fossil fuel the chemical industry
food companies
they will literally never do the right
thing unless they are forced to pay up
for it
and when that happens they typically
only do the right thing while they think
people are still paying attention then
they go right back to doing horrible
things
so again libertarians i beg you
read some corporate documents
then get back to me
on whether or not you think corporations
will inherently do the right thing
for the american public